[Music]
Rodney Carlisle is author of the
Complete Idiot's Guide to spies and
espionage he spoke about it recently at
the International Spy Museum in
Washington DC this is about 45 minutes I
am absolutely delighted to introduce dr.
Carlisle
Rodney Carlisle we have come to know him
quite well here at the Museum for
several reasons one because he is a very
widely published author on both military
history and other historical topics but
most particularly for two of the idiot's
guides that he's done people always
smile when I talk about the idiots guys
they're absolutely superb books I think
there are real contribution as an
introduction to whatever the subject is
dr. Carlisle has done two of the idiot's
guide and by the way it's the Complete
Idiot's Guide that of course could be
read in one of a couple of ways which I
will not go into but the Rodney Carlyle
has done both the idiots guide to
communism which is a very tricky subject
for many many people a lot of the young
people ask me why were we against
communism no concept of what what that
ideology was about or how we perceived
it as a threat and now he has done spies
and espionage and as I was mentioning to
him this is one of the very first books
that we pick up here in the museum when
we're trying to do some initial research
we don't know a name we can't remember
the case I'm forgetting more than I
remember so I'm not a dependable
resource this is one of our dependable
resources so it is a great introduction
to espionage to the field particularly
particularly human and I will tell you
this from a personal point of view I
have four daughters all of whom claim
that I never told them anything I did
and it's getting later and later in the
day for me to tell them what I did in
CIA where I was for 36 years
and I bought them each a copy of this
and inscribed it I said you know my
daughter's name I said now you'll know
so that at least gives them an
introduction currently dr. Carlisle is a
professor
emeritus at Rutgers University and he is
a senior associate of history associates
history Associates is here in Washington
area they're there they're hired guns
they're historians for hire and as I as
I like to tease them they're terrific
they have been advisors to the museum on
a couple of our programs and have been
advising us on one of our upcoming major
special exhibits so I think dr. Carlisle
was one of the founders of that
organization and they I think they have
made a great contribution certainly to
us at the museum he received his
doctorate from the University of
California and I mentioned he's done
some twenty books and this is his second
idiot's guide I have gotten to know him
over the course of history associates
advising us and it has just been a
pleasure he's extraordinarily
knowledgeable and with great insight
into this whole field so I'm absolutely
delighted to introduce dr. Rodney
Carlisle thank you very much Peter
I appreciate the turnout here today as
kind of as he says a little chilly for
spies so glad to see you all here
my approach so I'm going to use today is
to that you is one that you often see on
websites and that is what are the
frequently asked questions the fa Q's a
number of people have asked me about the
Complete Idiot's Guide and I've got a
whole list of frequently asked questions
to which I have developed some standard
replies and the first one was put to me
first by Jerry Haines was the former
chief historian of the CIA and who gave
me some help in reading over the book
and providing some editorial Corrections
and when he got done he said Rodney
whatever possessed you to write a
completely they had skyed and that's not
the only he's not the only person said
why did you ever do such a thing and I
think
well it seems like a facetious question
the answer could be regarded as a
serious one and that is I believe that
scholars spend too much time writing for
each other we do a lot of that it's
important it's how the field advances
but we have another responsibility and
that is a teaching responsibility to
bring what we've learned to to our
students in university and as we do in
history associates to bring it to other
clients and to the general public and so
my feeling in red and Complete Idiot's
Guide was to condense the field of
intelligence and twentieth-century
intelligence in particular and to make
it available to the general reader and
there is the line the Complete Idiot's
Guide of just explaining earlier that it
can be read either way is the question
is is that a complete guide or they
written for a complete idiot so I like
to think of it as a complete guide and
that none of my readers are really
complete idiots the another basis for
the for doing the book was that for the
last 10 years that I've taught at
Rutgers the most my most popular course
was a course in modern espionage and so
it was not impossible for me to do this
another question comes up in fact came
up this morning is well is there a is
there a copyright on this named complete
idiots guide and yes indeed there is you
just can't go and write a Complete
Idiot's Guide and and get it published
anywhere you want the Complete Idiot's
Guide series is produced by Alfa books
who have a New York office and another
office in Indianapolis and they have
over 700 titles ranging from the serious
ones like those that Peter mentioned and
there are several others completely its
guide to the FBI and and other
historical topics to topics you might
think are kind of frivolous like
completely hideous guide to teenage acne
or Complete Idiot's Guide to your first
date or
a complete idiots guide to how to throw
a party is if you needed a guide to that
so the reason for doing the book was to
translate what I'd been teaching into a
short format that would be available and
useful to the general reader now another
question that people have often asked me
is who is your favorite spy as as I work
through this and I had to think about
that one for a while because a lot of
these folks are very interesting and
fascinating but I think the one that
sort of caught my interest as a
youngster and who ends up having a nice
little section in the book is Cicero
Cicero was a Kosovo Kosovo Albanian who
ended up being rather multilingual and
in World War two surface of LA to the
British ambassador to Turkey and it
spoke English and French and was able to
fit into that role rather well and he
however had ambitions to make a lot of
money so he went to the German spy
apparatus and offered to provide them
with top-secret documents from the
British Embassy which he did by
photographing them with a little camera
and provided them a great great deal of
information about forthcoming Allied
invasion of Germany the understand a lot
of interesting aspects to Cicero's story
but the kind of the curious aspect is
that when he as working for the Germans
they were he was doing it for pay and he
insisted on being paid in British pounds
because he said even though I'm giving
you all this good information which
would help you win the war you're not
smart enough to win the war and so I
want to be paid in British pounds
because I'll have them after the war and
of course the Germans were not happy
with that attitude but they paid him in
British pounds and at the end of the war
he'd accumulated something like 200,000
pounds which was a huge fortune in 1945
and he went to buy a
a resort hotel for cash and this was had
been his dream to be a hotelier run a
nice restaurant and so on and when he
got a call for the bank said we're sorry
to let you know that all the money
you've deposited is counterfeit and so
and that's not the end of the story as
Paul Harvey would say there's more to
this story he sued the German government
after the war for a false payment and he
wanted to be paid in legitimate British
pounds and is he lost that lawsuit so he
finally he sold his book for profit and
they and it was eventually made into a
movie Five Fingers was starred James
Mason and I think that's one of the
reasons as a young kid I got interested
in espionage was watching Five Fingers
which is very well done movie and I
recommend you rent it from Blockbuster
so anyway I he's my favorite spy I think
and I gave him a page or two in the book
another question that people have asked
me is and this one's not so easy to
answer is what country in the 20th
century had the best spies
it's um actually it's good question and
it's very difficult to answer in some
ways during the Cold War the Soviet
Union had the best HUMINT apparatus in
in many ways they were good at
recruiting they're good at motivating
their spies they had excellent
tradecraft they knew how to evade
surveillance and knew how to use dead
drops and knew how to you know have
cutouts to be able to get the
information from the agent they knew how
to compartmentalize or compartment eyes
their organizations so that if one
person was uncovered the rest of the
network wouldn't be revealed they're
good at all those things and the by
contrast the United States didn't seem
to be quite as good that's on the
surface and that's not a bad surface
answer but there's more to intelligence
than the field officers and the agents
the crucial part of intelligence is
whether it gets used the analysis and
the utilization of intelligence the
Soviet Union was not always that great
there are several notorious examples of
the Soviet Union being provided with
excellent intelligence information but
then ignoring it the most famous case is
the case of our well several cases right
before World War two the German had the
or during world war two the Germans were
about to invade the Soviet Union from at
least three excellent sources that
Stalin was informed that the invasion
was imminent and he refused to believe
it
the sources included Richard Sorge ax
who was a very clever spy for the Soviet
Union based in Japan
another source was a ultra information
that is decoded a enigma transmitted
transmissions that were that the British
had decoded and were were relaying back
to Germany I mean from Germany to the
Soviet Union the Soviets and Stalin
particular refused to believe it
and this reflects a deeper flaw in in
their whole system and that is what's
sometimes called bosses amande that is
that you know if the boss doesn't want
to believe something he sets up a set of
beliefs that are standard and then if
you try to say something goes against
what the boss says it is discounted so
so that you might say why the Soviets
had a good system and good networks
about collecting human intelligence they
were not very good at utilizing it and
another way to answer that question
about who had the best system is to say
well
by contrast the Soviet system we were
pretty good at Techint and it should go
through this museum you'll see a lot of
examples of that the our satellite
system systems are our decoding systems
have a lot of aspects that are superior
and so you can't answer you can always
say and you can answer that one question
about who had the best spies or who had
the best spy system with another
question saying which which do you mean
human tor tech in tor what kind of
espionage are you talking about
so that's that's my approach to that and
that shows up in this book another
question that comes up which I've sort
of alluded to already and that is why is
espionage so fascinating
we find the museum crowded here of
course that's partly due to their
excellent job that they do but it's also
due to the intrinsic nature of espionage
that makes it fascinating this book is
selling a lot better than the University
Press books I did and hopefully will
continue to do so and the question is
why why as it's been are such a
fascinating subject and I think it goes
to something very basic in human nature
that makes things like detective stories
fascinating and treasure hunts
fascinating and perhaps archeology of
ancient civilizations fascinating and
that is something that is was once
concealed has been revealed that that
peeks something very basic in human
nature that there was something once
secret that is no longer secret and that
you can now look at so you feel a sense
of reward that this you know these folks
didn't know about or the general public
didn't know about this but now I know
about it and it just it catches that
something that child and all of us that
isn't interested in discovering the
unknown so I think this museum does a
great job of that and that's one of the
reasons spy literature is fascinating
another question people have asked me is
did I learn anything special in writing
this book you know I knew quite a bit
about the topic before well one thing I
learned is how hard is to write a book
in four months the Complete Idiot's
Guide folks give you a deadline and once
they accept your proposal they'll give
you a date when it is due and then they
because they have to make it into the
bookstores at a certain certain date but
on a more serious level I learned but
and you often learn a lot when you write
a book about your subject because you
have to think at the next level up you
can you no longer focus just on the on
the minute shoot minute you I little
details that you begin focused on how it
all ties together into a theme on how it
links together and several themes come
up in this and among the things I
learned were these that there are lots
of problems recur the present the
question I mentioned about Stalin I was
not unique to Stalin and in fact it
seemed rather familiar after 9/11 there
were signals weren't there that there
was going to be something happening the
investigations into the intelligence
community after 9/11 focused a lot on
the question of why wasn't this
information about the potential use of
aircraft as weapons why wasn't it ever
acted on or thought about or why or in
the parlance of the press in those days
right after 9/11
why was there failure to connect the
dots and it's in this case it's not
exactly bossism but it's it's something
a little more profound and that is that
good intelligence to be good has to show
you something that is valuable that that
is something that is that you would not
otherwise know it has to be something
that is unexpected I mean if you
expected it you wouldn't need the
intelligence apparatus
figure it out so by its nature good
intelligence taps into a something that
doesn't fit your existing paradigm one
of dr. Cameron's favorite word's
it doesn't fit your system it doesn't
fit your preconceptions to be good
intelligence right there's the paradox
if it doesn't fit your preconceptions
you're not going to want to believe it
because there'll be 99 out of 100 people
will say well that doesn't it's
unexpected who ever heard of using an
airplane for yeah thought of using
kerosene to knock down a building
you know let's look for high explosives
or let's look for something you know it
just didn't fit the pattern and just as
it didn't fit the pattern for Stalin to
believe Richard sorge's information that
the Germans were about to break their
alliance with them and invade so it's
this is a recurrent problem in
intelligence it's not just that people
aren't good analysts or that they aren't
good gatherers it's when it comes in and
if it is valuable it if it's really
valuable it won't fit your
preconceptions and you have a big job
involved in trying to make that strange
information become sensible and being
able to act on it and in fact some other
another frequently asked question ties
in to that same thing and were there any
lessons for from this book that can be
applied to the war on terror and I think
that's one of them that we that the
current administration and the current
people in homeland security and and the
other agencies that are trying to
protect United States now need to be
able to look at the unexpected they have
to be able to think freshly they have to
be able to think creatively
and and perhaps I ought to have a few of
them read the Complete Idiot's Guide all
right now let me I will throw it open
and see if there any other questions
that you folks might have we can take a
few minutes to do that I promise to give
20 minutes and I think I did just about
20 minutes
I think dr. Kim I wanted to ask me more
about what I do at history associates
that's where we read all the aliens no
as Peter explained to history associates
is a a firm which we established about
20 years ago 21 years ago now and we're
based in Rockville Maryland and we
provide historical services on contract
to government agencies to nonprofit
organizations to private corporations
and these include not only writing
history books on contract and but a
whole range of other kinds of services
including assisting museums in their
research and design or research behind
their design we don't do the design work
and litigation support we provide
attorneys with evidentiary material
drawn from the archives and we also
organize and maintain historical
archives for institutions so four of us
started it and now there are about 40 of
us working on the project I participated
in history associates over the years
while I continue to teach at Rutgers and
that required a bit of a juggling act
yes Peter seek and did you get any help
from the government from the from the
intelligence agencies I didn't seek it
exactly but at the end I thought they
the publishers asked me who would be
able to write a good preface and I
thought of the various folks I knew in
the who had served in the government and
I went to Gerry Haynes who was the chief
historian at the CIA and he very
graciously read the manuscript and
offered some comments and some
corrections and said you can't say this
where did you get that I took a few of
those little things out and but for the
most part of it I didn't and it was I
mean I didn't have any classified
sources this is all drawn from the open
literature it just sometimes the open
literature or the published literature
contains things
the government can neither confirm nor
deny and in fact I put a disclaimer in
the front about that but I didn't go to
any official sources for it yes go ahead
community in the form of buying lots of
copies of your book well I don't know
that like I probably don't have a need
to know and I don't think there's a lot
of completing working in those agencies
I hope that's good the time frame that
you looked at as far as intelligence is
concerned at least as far as American
intelligence yes
what kind of balanced you put between
human sources and technical sources as
to as to which seem to provide not
necessarily volume but the best to tell
the both usable intelligence judgment
that you the place on that it changed
with time the answer that question
changed with time that is I think that
there was very little what we would
today call check int in World War two
there was a you know there was
decryption okay during the Cold War that
also changed with time the American in
the 1970s there was a concerted effort
after after the church committing
investigations and the revelations of a
lot of the things had gone on in the
intelligence agencies which I go into in
here there was a kind of backlash and
the intelligence agencies began a
concerted effort to to downplay human
sources and to play up technical sources
I've put that in the late 70s so from
the late 70s to the present I say the
United States has as has placed a lot
more emphasis on technical means of
collection and has done pretty well with
it I don't that's a pretty general
answer but I think your question was
it's a general question right yeah right
I would say that's the case I don't you
know another problem
in fact I could have put this on my FAQ
list here is that in writing the history
of intelligence we confront a basic
problem and that is and other people
come in on this is that you don't find
out about operations that were really
successful
I mean if it's really successful it's
never revealed and so when you're if you
were to that's why so many books about
the CIA are a history of CIA failures
because that's all the public knows the
real CIA success stories are actually
there some of them are being revealed in
the studies in intelligence that is
published quarterly I guess or is it
quarterly from the CIA but most of the
things that they reveal are pretty old
you know from before the 60s so you know
everybody's heard of the Bay of Pigs but
if there was simultaneously an operation
that wasn't a fiasco in the early 1960s
we may not have heard about it yet
because the sources and methods are
still being protected you know so
so that's why it's difficult to say
whether our human has been all that
successful because you know you only
hear about the goof ups and the people
to get caught are the things that get
revealed and so I'm not sure this way
out of that dilemma yes go ahead in the
room that we're in is called banana
Friedman yes espionage names to all of
the yeah all of our rooms and Valona as
I think probably most folks in here know
was the cracking of the KGB code are
portions of it around in the middle of
World War two that was not officially
Declassified as a secret until 50 years
later 1995 my question to you as a
historian is were you aware of Venona
in unofficial channels prior to 1995 did
you have any knowledge of Venona and and
the results of it not really no and
there was a Venona conference held over
at the Defense University here which I
attended just a lot almost out of luck
although I was at that time teaching the
course and that's when I learned the
most about it I think before that
conference I had heard a little bit
about it
in fact it
it explained a lot you know you it was
very hard to understand how they tracked
down Klaus Fuchs before the Venona
papers were released the sort of the
standard interpretation until the early
90s was that well somehow the secrets
that Igor Gouzenko who was a spy clerk
in in Ottawa Canada I mean a
cryptography Clark working for the
Soviets he defected walked out with a
bunch of documents one hundred and fifty
some documents that revealed the atomic
spy network but they did they revealed
by code names you know they did in the
documents that he had with him that he
took in his shirt didn't really say who
these folks were and somehow the first
histories of the Klaus Fuchs matter and
so on sort of suggested that somehow the
Gouzenko material led to Klaus Fuchs but
it wasn't until after the Venona
revelations that we began to realize
that all right it was a little bit more
to that story and it was through the
Venona decrypt that they began to get
the information of about Klaus Fuchs
that would allow the FBI to track down
and identify who was the most likely
leak from Los Alamos and then from that
leak a whole chain of leaks developed I
mean not leaks holds a chain of
detective work developed leading to
Harry gold and from Harry Harry gold to
the Rosenbergs and those gaps were
filled once we learned the bonanno
material I have a section in the book
called post Venona revisionism and I
think that what's happened in recent
espionage history is that the
revelations from the Venona decrypts as
well as a couple of other revelations
where they the russians opened up their
archives and allowed some american
scholars to come in and british scholars
as well as the Metropia archive which
was consisted of a an archivist
who worked for years for the KGB but
whose job it was to file their files
decided that this stuff was pretty hot
and he took a rock to his dacha he took
he hand copied it and took it out to his
doctor kept it in the trunk and he
finally brought that the mitrik and
materials out so those three things the
the Venona material the research in the
KGB archives and the Metropia archives
put together and published in the mid
90s have have led to a lot of
revisionism the most striking and I
mentioned this in the Complete Idiot's
Guide to communism is that modern
scholarship now understands that the
communist parties around the world from
the 1920s to the 1990s were not simply
ideologically supportive of Moscow they
were directed from Moscow they were
funded from Moscow and they were
consciously used by the Soviet Union as
recruiting grounds for intelligence
agents so you know in 1955 the only
people who believed that were right-wing
in the United States were right-wing red
Bader's in 1995 no matter what your
political orientation is if you're a
serious scholar on the subject you come
to accept the fact that the Communist
Party in the United States as well as
around the world in other countries
worked hand in glove as an instrument of
Moscow policy and that's become
clarified by those kinds of inside
documents that we're not available until
the 90s oh do you think that you're
taking what you just said that's modern
scholarship yeah
recognizing more the impact of
intelligence or lack of it in not just
current events but any historical
affairs as you know we went through the
post-vietnam Peru the Vietnam and then
post Vietnam period where in many
universities the subject of intelligence
was was really not treated as a subject
in any serious way do you find in your
contacts with with a khadeem that there
is a greater acceptance of the role of
intelligence whether and I'm not asking
about agreeing or disagreeing with any
particular sound yeah so some this is
not just post monona either some of it
had to do with it you could write a
history of the history of military
affairs and intelligence that would
reveal some of this but some of it goes
back to the revelations in the 1970s of
ultra if you if depending on when a
history was published you'll get a
completely different flavor if you read
a history of the battles of World War
two of say of the battles in North
Africa published before 1970 hardly any
intelligence mentioned tactical
intelligence is mentioned but there's at
up until 1970 there was no public
revelation of the cracking of the Enigma
codes so the fact that the British Army
in North Africa knew Rommels
dispositions and numbers of Tanks and
went how many were under repair and so
on and when the ships were coming across
the Mediterranean and how to target them
and when to target them and that wasn't
revealed until the publication of the
ultra secret
I think the publication date for that is
73 or 75 I have to check my bibliography
but so
there's been an evolution in the degree
to which say let's a military historians
place an emphasis on the role of this
kind of high-level intelligence and now
I would say as people write to Paul
political history of the Cold War in the
post monona era it's pretty hard for
them to ignore this material so I think
you're right I have a little bit of a
skewed view of this because I read a lot
of this stuff you know and but there
been an awfully been a number of very
good books the Haunted wood by Weinstein
is another one I mentioned the Metro can
archive is if the Metro can archive is
rather encyclopedic in fact mentioning
encyclopedias I have another
encyclopedia forthcoming with Emmy sharp
company called encyclopedia of
intelligence and counterintelligence and
one of your former employees here elect
Alexis wrote two or three entries for
that as well as some folks from history
associates but it has over it's over an
800 page encyclopedia due to come out
later this year and we've had many
serious scholars from around the world
from Australia and Britain Canada mostly
english-speaking countries so we had a
couple Hungarians and a few others write
entries and they we have two prophecies
to the book one by Oleg Kalugin as a
former KGB officer so the other by
Robert Gates is trying to even hand it
there but yes I'd say there's a there's
more serious literature as I said my
views all skewed because I tend to look
at this stuff and read a lot about it
but I think it's beginning to change the
way people think of those events yes go
ahead
you make an interesting point about the
dilemma of the
intelligence community keeping things
secret and at the same time letting
these things that are emerged slowly in
the thus the popular interest certainly
last 15-20 years of public interest and
desire for more information they toes
community can you comment on what you
think the impact that has been on on
American intelligence and the
government or public financing of that
intelligence
that's all which it's a hard question I
think well it seems to me that there's
more public support in in the 21st
century for intelligence work than there
certainly than there was in the late 70s
and the reasons for that are several
that have compounded some of the very
recent events I mean the the war on
terror I think the American people and
politicians of many stripes accept the
seriousness of that conflict and they
have disagreements about it to contact
other kind and the conduct of it but I
think that it would be very hard to find
a politician says well we should we
should start underfunding the CIA today
we should start underfunding the
Homeland Security because after all it's
a waste of money I mean was that's right
that's right and that was the other part
of my point in the 1970s that was an
attitude that had kept him because they
felt that the Central Intelligence
Agency and the other intelligence
agencies had abused their power and had
infringed civil liberties and in all
kinds of ways by tapping telephones and
so on and entities some of the
techniques that have been adopted in by
the FBI and and CIA appeared to push the
edges of morality and the edges of
American views of civil liberties and so
in 1976 1977 you would not find if you
took a poll and compared a poll from
1976 to one in 2004 you would find a big
difference but it's
partly due to the war on terror but it's
also partly due to these revelations
that have come out in other words if
they if there had been no 9/11 I said I
think that by now there would still be
more support for intelligence activities
than there had been in 1978 1979 any
other questions I can put on my FAQ list
here yes intelligence of the at the end
of the Classical period of the Cold War
in 1988 990 how do things change once
the Soviet Union is no longer the
singler singular opposition I think you
probably better asking someone in the
intelligence community than someone
outside but I can give you my opinion
I've never afraid to give it a video not
anything and my thinking is that there
was a little bit of a period of
disorientation of with no longer having
a main adversary and it wasn't quite
clear in 1989 1991 that al-qaeda or
fundamentalist Islam would represent a
major threat to the United States so
though I think there was a period
disorientation another sort of immediate
development of course was the Persian
Gulf War and in the Persian Gulf War it
was a concern with what we would call
military intelligence or tactical
intelligence and the and also the use of
deception these are classical
intelligence techniques you remember
general Schwarzkopf and his famous Hail
Mary
invasion to the left flank which was
kept concealed very well and there had
been a deception operation which kind of
falls in the category of intelligence
operations to convince the Iraqis in
that war that there was going to be an
amphibious invasion by Marines
into Kuwait all of that was very
carefully done and there was a lot of
interest and support for that and and
the intelligence agencies were involved
in it but that's military that's not
high level you might say international
intelligence operations and I think it
took a while for for the intelligence
community and I think it's still taking
them a while I think they're still
trying to recruit folks to speak Arabic
and and Pashtun and all the other
languages that they need to deal with a
changed world I don't know that's very
good answer and I don't have any special
insight information but I'm pretty sure
that there was a period of
disorientation from you know where the
bad guys no longer bad guys what do you
do next
like a lot of folks retired right then
another question no yes it is guide to
telogen completed his guide to
intelligence presumably you're not just
covering the Soviets in the you know I
had to make a decision I I know where
your question is going on where do I
start where do I end and so and you do
do evaluate the other intelligence
service as well any sense at all well
here's the way I tried to treat this I
treated it the way I did my college
course there would be a way to teach
intelligence and it is taught in some
ways it's from ancient times to the
present if you teach it as a two
semester course you know with the first
semester running up say to the Civil War
and with tremendous examples from
Elizabethan England and
from Napoleonic France and the
Napoleonic Wars of Britain and France
the American Revolution and I didn't do
that no it isn't I know but when I
focused on the 20th century and then in
the 20th century I tried to I focused on
fundamentally four countries the Soviet
Union of course Great Britain and the
United States and Germany and I mean
there's a lot of other stuff going on
there's some Israel has an interesting
agency South Africa before the
changeover government had a kind of
tough-minded agency the there are
intelligence agencies in China about
which the public knows very little a lot
of the stuff gets covered in this new
encyclopedia that I'm editing but my
feeling was for the idiot or the
completed hit or the general reader that
the interest was primarily World War two
and and the Cold War and so the role of
Great Britain
and the role of Soviet Union got to play
I you know I barely mentioned the SD ECE
the French agency in in passing I mean I
don't say anything about South American
agencies or Asian agencies because it
was couldn't be an encyclopedia so I had
to make some decisions but and I think
that's where the general readers
interest lies in fact I think that's
sort of the emphasis in this museum is
the cold war world war two in fact
that's one reason I think this book it's
useful to the folks of the museum
because their thinking was very much
like mine of what the public wants to
know about and what is interesting
what's fascinating in espionage history
I mean I don't believe you have a big
coverage of the Elizabethan era here you
could but your tennis would probably
fall off and
although it's pretty fascinating stuff
you could have a room on on that I'm not
suggesting it though I didn't I'd hate
to see a room completely skipped by the
audience that comes through
yes go ahead well one of the interesting
parts I think about the history of this
is as you peel back the onion cover more
and more as a restoring looking at
reading contemporary documents what you
find is that things you may have
suspected the new informations revealed
sort of connect connects the dots if you
will for example during the Rodney's was
talking about the people who were read
Bader's and the congressional committees
and people like that who if you read
what they are saying and what they're
doing in the 40s and 50s Richard Nixon
when he was in the house on American
Activities Committee it's quite clear
they're getting information from
somewhere they've got the people right
but you don't know how their
investigation they have forgotten so the
suspect suspicions would be well they're
getting material from the FBI or or the
later the CIA
46 and and indeed as you as materials
get released as that's what happened and
you look at the Far East and read
newspapers and you discover that the
Japanese have a very very sophisticated
technical intelligence gathering system
that just reported in the papers that
they pick up a lot of signals out of
Russian Korea China and while we don't
know much about that officially you
eventually people will be able to I
think connect those dots to see where
the agencies in other parts of the world
we know about the Israeli intelligence
but because they work too closely we're
learning now a little more about
Canadian intelligence and the news the
other night about 60 minutes to add
something on about a
suppose it alleged al-qaeda operative
you pick this up you put a sort of file
on this side eventually the information
will turn up but that's that's the
intrigue and the interest I think of
learning more and more about how the
intelligence community works well I
think in may be buried in that is a
question in that and and and the
question might be you know how does how
does a is what role can the historian
play in unraveling appealing back the
onion and I think we are doing that the
book by Weinstein for example does it's
called the Haunted wood he does a great
job of showing some of these connections
that were completely on not uncovered
before and showing some of the sources
for Richard Nixon's information that
sort of thing so it I'd say as time goes
on we get a fuller and fuller picture
and again that's what makes it
fascinating okay Peter
the Complete Idiot's Guide to spies and
espionage is published by Alfa books
visit idiots guides comm for more
information